I don't really care where I start in the
research spectrum
I might start completely solving the
problem from scratch I might start by
capitalizing on other people work I
might put pieces together to make it
work the important goal to me is to have
something that works for the purpose of
the customer you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen using
[Music]
machine learning is a powerful tool that
enables conversational agents to provide
general question-answer services but in
domains with more specific taxonomy x'
or simply four requests that are longer
and more complicated than play baby
shark custom conversational AI has long
been the province of large enterprises
with big budgets but not for long thanks
to the work of dr. Rita Mansour a
principal software engineering manager
for Microsoft's language understanding
service or Lewis she and her colleagues
are using the emerging science of
machine teaching to help domain experts
build bespoke AI models with little data
and know machine learning expertise on
today's podcast dr. Mansour gives us a
brief history of conversational machines
at Microsoft tells us all about Lewis
one of the first Microsoft products to
deploy machine teaching concepts in
real-world verticals and explains how an
unlikely combination of engineering
skills science skills entrepreneurial
skills and not taking no for an answer
helped make automated customer
engagement and business functions more
powerful more accessible and more
intelligent that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
rehab Mansour welcome to the podcast
thank you
I love situating my guests at the
beginning of every podcast is such a
research II term so let's situate you
you're a principal software engineering
manager and you run the language
understanding service aka Louis and I'm
absolutely gonna have you tell us about
Louis in a bit but let's start with the
macro view of who you are and what you
do what big problems are you trying to
address and what gets you up in the
morning hmm
I've started that effort of the language
understanding service with a machine
teaching innovation group almost five
years ago and we're trying to solve a
very interesting problem which is how
can we get people and domain experts who
don't have a lot of machine learning
expertise or even don't have data or
don't know what are the pieces that they
need to put together to build an AI
model so we're trying to get those
people on board to the AI world okay
because those people have lots of
problems that AI can help them with so
we're trying to meet those people where
they are today helping them with AI
solutions powerful solutions to their
problems in the past
AI was only coming from the giant tech
companies that can afford having the AI
experience and they have enough data but
then like now enterprises and developers
who want to build intelligent systems
how can they unlock the power of AI I
think this is the exact problem we're
trying to solve before we get technical
I want to talk a little more about you
because you bring what I would call
hybrid vigor to the research party you
have roots across the tech spectrum from
academic research to applied research to
product and engineering and not
necessarily in that order
so tell us a bit about how all these
parts make up your unified whole and how
it speaks to the work you do yeah so
actually I didn't mean to be all over
the place I think the journey of my
career has pushed me into starting
Engineering and back in the time I was
very interested in doing software
development coding and design and all
that that was my passion back then and
then working in the product brings a lot
of Frigga and you see all the real-world
problems and what can be done what
cannot be done and so forth but all
throughout my career in engineering I
always had the science appetite I like
to clarify things and play with that
ambiguous and being an engineer has part
of that because you need to figure
things out but there is more to the
dimension of science than just being an
engineer because you start with a bunch
of hypotheses where like we knew nothing
about how to solve that problem and then
and then we start tackling the problems
through the scientific method so I
always knew during my engineering career
that at one point I want to explore the
science aspect of life and when the
right time came I joined the ph.d
program yeah but then when I was done
with my PhD the question came to my mind
what should I be doing and then I worked
a little bit as a professor because this
is the thing I didn't do before with my
PhD I did the engineering part so I
tried to explore options that was not a
job for me I liked the job of a
professor is to make a Delta change in
the student life and I love working at a
fast pace with the smartest people in
the world so this is why I like it
professor job was not for me move me to
a faster lane exactly it get me to a
faster Lane so I joined Microsoft
research and I started exploring that
sweet spot for me and that's exactly
where I found my real passion so yes
engineering is great academic research
is awesome but what's more awesome for
me was how can I build something that
solves a scientific problem but yet it's
useful to people you joined Microsoft
Research in 2012 and you came as a
senior NLP applied researcher yes in the
advanced technology lab in Cairo yes and
you worked on several language
innovations that ended up actually
shipping in products so tell us a bit in
turn about the work you did in sentiment
this topic detection and keyphrase
extraction because those are some of
your big innovations yes back in the
time when I joined the advanced
technology lab in Cairo my mission was
to focus on making an impact out of
whatever innovations that we work on so
I always start with the customer I don't
like to start with a problem that
interests me it has to be a problem that
interests me and solves the problem so
first I went and like talked to multiple
groups or either doing NLP at the moment
or have plans to do NLP like the Azure
machine learning team so when we started
talking then I wanted to come up with my
research agenda and at that time like I
figured out a bunch of problems that
have to do with I would say the basic
fundamental blocks of building NLP
stacks so they started abstracting the
different problems I got from the
different groups and tried to put it in
one technology that can serve multiple
groups so that we can like really make
an impact on multiple ones and back in
the time those were the three key pieces
that we landed as important across
multiple groups and they ended up
landing in production for many of these
groups these are very classic NLP
problems that many people have in the
company have kind of tackled the other
main activity I did was looking at who
in the company is doing that right who
in MSR or non MSR groups that are
working on that actively and then I
started a bunch of collaborations so for
example the sentiment analysis I found
that there were two main players in that
area and I found that they are already
talking but kind of each of them is
working on a different approach and my
goal was always to solve what the
product group wants right so I was the
person among the three who played that
role with that collaboration between the
two groups and myself there is that
example but then there was another
example of topic detection which was
completely something that for example
Bing News wanted to tag their news data
with topics that might not necessarily
be mentioned in the news articles but by
finding the semantic relatedness between
the content of the article and other web
data we can get to that level of
detecting the topic but that
not pension that work was not available
in other groups and that was something
we started working on and moved forward
I don't really care where I start in the
research spectrum
I might start completely solving the
problem from scratch I might start by
capitalizing on other people work I
might put pieces together to make it
work the important goal to me is to have
something that works for the purpose of
the customer well your work now falls
under the big umbrella of human language
technologies which many have called the
crown jewel of AI give us a brief
overview of the HLT landscape right now
specifically this movement toward
conversational AI what's the state of
the art right now and how's your work
situated in it so I think I've been in
general interested in human languages
and how to get machines to understand
human languages to maybe do more for
humans in their day to day so part of
that has been the conversational AI
space this is one vertical I would say
that emerge from the fact that we can
make it possible for machines to
understand human languages then that
unlocks a bunch of opportunities for
example how do we do customer support
today customer support is all about
Asians talking to humans starting to
solve their problems if we can automate
pieces we can save those enterprises a
lot of money right there is other
verticals within conversationally yeah I
like finance and banking and you need to
do more task completion so between my
customer support question-answering and
task completion that is very specific to
the business I think that's where the HL
team comes into play in the
conversational AI space because
businesses have started paying attention
to the fact that that can help them a
lot with changing the way they do
business today there was a lot of
traction to that space and that's right
the way rang a bell for me and I think
this is the part I love to play at like
this is where I bring in my engineering
skills my science skills and I would say
even my entrepreneurial skills right
until like looking at how can we take
that technology and make it work for
that specific vertical
to solve that specific problem
[Music]
I want to turn our attention
specifically to machine teaching for a
second because it's the technical
foundation of what we'll spend most of
our time talking about today I recently
had your colleague Patrice Simard on the
podcast and he gave us a fantastic
overview of machine teaching but for
those people who didn't hear that
podcast and they can go back and hear it
if they want and even for those who
might have heard it but can't remember
everything let's review what is machine
teaching and how is it different from
traditional machine learning the goal of
machine teaching and transition machine
learning is to build an accurate
knowledge singles right so a user was
using either would have the goal in mind
to build a model a good model right
but then the what and how is what's
different so usually to build any model
from data you need to have some
knowledge that exists somewhere in
machine teaching it's about extracting
the knowledge from the teacher so it has
the human in the loop providing the
necessary knowledge about the domain so
that we can build an AI model specific
to that domain traditional machine
learning is about extracting knowledge
from data so using the compute power to
extract the knowledge from huge amounts
of data and that's where deep learning
and other keywords transfer learning
come into play so when and why machine
teaching can be useful I would say in
situations where there isn't enough
label data already available and you
want to build a custom AI model that's
specific to your domain but you don't
have machine learning expertise between
the three pillars that I just mentioned
this is when machine teaching shines as
a good solution versus traditional
machine learning if a problem has lots
of label data just go on with
traditional machine learning because
deep learning would shine way better but
machine teaching is when you don't have
data you don't have machine learning
expertise and you want to build a custom
models mm-hmm so machine teaching is all
about custom AI when you don't have
labels or when you don't have machine
learning expertise this is exactly the
problem resolving and we're providing
the first programming language of AI
what we're providing is a teaching
language
for humans to teach the machine so that
we can build an AI model in the
background so the way we extract the
knowledge from the teacher is basically
by offering some language they can
communicate to the tool with and we
translate that language that humans
provide into a model and that's exactly
where the customization part comes into
play so for example you have a bunch of
vocabulary that's very specific to the
domain and in machine teaching we give
you a venue to provide that specific
locale those words in exactly and it's
not only words because in machine
teaching we have a lot of analogy
between machine teaching and programming
so we're trying to learn from the six
decades of programming how to build AI
models we look into programming and we
see how developers build their programs
the first thing they do is the design
and decompose right so it's hard to
solve a complex problem we have to
divide and conquer so that we can share
pieces of code reuse pieces of code
that's exactly the core of machine
teaching and that's why we're building
custom AI models in a different way
different from traditional machine
learning let's talk about Louis
Microsoft what you call entry point into
the machine teaching market yes you
founded it in collaboration with the
machine teaching group in Microsoft
Research in 2015
yes and then it moved from research to
product landing in office just this year
yes so this is sort of a multi-level
progressive question forgive me for that
and I'll circle back if necessary but
tell us the story of how Lewis was born
how it grew where it is now and what
aspirations it has for the future
so back in 2014
advanced the technology lab where I was
working Khatri or get to xiao tong hong
XD i was running the speech services in
the company and XD was fascinated by
solving real-life problems and we had
that expertise in natural and processing
but then he wanted us to do a bigger
impact by kind of taking the technology
even further to adopt millions of users
back in the time we were looking at way
to TI that
Facebook acquired and Microsoft was
looking at the technology and started
seeing all the virtual assistants space
that's where we need the kind of way to
TI technology and then we looked around
and we said oh hey why don't we build it
ourselves and xD back then believe that
we have the right talent to build that
so the task was basically we need to put
Microsoft in that space of virtual
assistants how can we build a bunch of
tools that can enable different
enterprises to build their own virtual
assistants but then what if an
enterprise company or a bank wants to
build their own assistant to help their
customers or to serve their internal
employees then we need a bunch of tools
right so language understanding has been
a key part in the speech sack so speech
comes as an audio translated into text
using the automatic speech recognition
ASR and then out of that text we need to
apply language understanding right to
extract what's the user intention what
are the key entities or keywords in the
utterance but then understanding the
content of the utterance is very
important right translating the
unstructured data or human language into
a structure that the machine can
understand an act upon is a stage what
we call language understanding so XD
started asking us with that and then we
looked around in the company like with
my practical mentality should we just go
ahead and like build something from
scratch because there isn't any
technology that we can leverage or
should we just leverage something and
back in the time I got to know patrice
amar who's like i would say that
godfather of machine teaching and we
figured out that that technology can
with more tweaking can work really well
in building a third-party offering for
language understanding but when we
started the journey we didn't have
really in mind that we're building that
product that I can see today we were
testing the water I would say because
the whole market was new there wasn't
any of the tech giants playing in that
space back in 2014 even BOTS were not
trendy right so we didn't know what's
possible why that technology is useful
we knew that Microsoft needs to play a
key role in the Virtual Assistants space
right or the conversationally ice pair
but we didn't know how that would look
like what did the shape of the market or
any of that
we tested the water we took some baby
steps I would say so we got the
technology catered it for the
conversationally eyespace we branded it
luis and it became one of the early
cognitive services when cognitive
services went out and he just just to
clarify Luis stood for language and
understanding intelligence service and
you still call it Louis
but you've dropped the intelligence it's
just language understanding service yes
because back in the time we just
launched it the the language
understanding intelligence service
acronym Louis and then later on with the
marketing team and the branding team we
dropped the word intelligent and we kept
the language understanding service but
the acronym Louis had a lot of mindshare
by the time and we kept it so Louis when
we launched it in 2015 in private
preview we were only in lining up I
would say 200 developers we just wanted
200 developers to come and use the
system so that we can understand how
they can use it why it's useful and so
forth
and then we got the cue of 10k
developers ten thousand yeah ten
thousand asking for the service the
service and the problem back then is we
needed a lot of engineering work to make
it scale and and really work but the
traction we got in the market and the
fact that other companies are investing
in that so because of that traction XD
and harry shum said ok we need to invest
more in making this a product so I got a
little bit more engineering resources
and I worked closely with Patrice and
his machine teaching group to move that
forward with more features build it at
scale and make it work for enterprise
and then in ignite in 2015 it was the
first time to support a non-english
language in Louis so he supported
Chinese so XD and Harry announced the
Chinese support for Louis in China and
then we started lending more and more
customers over time and we're today at
hundreds of thousands of customers using
our platform and now conversationally I
is the thing and all the giant companies
are players in the space and interesting
enough at first we wanted to enable
speech interfaces to some devices later
on there was the text-based chat boss
then even I would say interactive gaming
it's coming into play so there were
scenarios we haven't thought through
when we build the product but then we
found that some of the customers are
using it just for that right so see this
is exactly what gets me up in the
morning coming to the office you feel
like you're doing something that is very
leading in the market we're creating
that new market we're drawing the
features of that new market we're
defining it right so that is like lots
of fun but then the journey of Louis
didn't stop there we took it all the way
to general availability on Azure and it
became like a generally available
service with an SLA and all that right
so it became really a more mature
product I would say towards the end of
2017 at some point we said okay here's
the machine teaching technology in the
form of a technology that serves
conversationally i but machine teaching
is a way of doing custom AI models and
the input could be a signal or image or
text Louis is very focused on text but
then we wanted to look into how can we
make even bigger scope of Louis to solve
other problems in the text space because
that's my area of expertise right so I'm
kind of biased but but then in March
2018 we put together a proposal for
growing the scope of Louis to be able to
use machine teaching but to do
processing of long documents so
basically enabling customers to build
custom document classifiers entity
extractors which are very key to the
document processing pipelines but custom
models right and that's the reason
behind the recent reorg first unifying
the machine teaching science group with
the product which is Louis and putting
them together in one group in office so
now we're serving conversationally i
over azure an office and we're serving
document understanding in office and
Azure as well
this is the part of the podcast where I
ask what keeps you up at night mm-hmm
and we've been talking about a couple of
ideas that could have unintended
consequences like giving machines human
language capabilities and giving humans
who have no expertise in ml the tools to
build their own models you know when
we're creating a new market or
redefining the way people do businesses
and this is not specific to that area
but in general on the edge between
science and product yes there exists a
lot of unknowns right and a lot of
questions and assumptions that we make
on the way because of who we are mm-hmm
right but then how much would that
resonate with the real people when we
meet them where they are is a different
question so what keeps me up at night is
the general question of what that
product be successful or not how can we
make it useful what problems is it
trying to solve that it's not solving
today and it's supposed to be solving
these unanswered questions and those
assumptions that we take from the
technology putting it in the product is
what keeps me up at night because if we
do it right if we keep validating and be
humble to take feedback from customers
and do that that is like kind of a
solution to this anxiety that I might
have but I figured out that process of
how to collect feedback how to speak to
customers what language are we speaking
to customers and so forth so you can
translate that into a science problem
that you communicate back to the science
team to solve it so I think this is
exactly the dynamic I'm kind of good at
or the thing I'm doing day-to-day it's
like speaking to the science people
speaking to my engineering team and
speaking to the customers those three
key stakeholders you need to do a lot of
translation in the loop to get it right
that kind of loop and these kind of
questions and the input I get from
customers is what gives me up at night
how to put it together how
translated into a problem that I give
back to the science team and say hey
this is what we need to solve
you've been interesting and somewhat
peripatetic story I love that I could
use that word in a podcast how did you
get started in computer science where
has your journey taking you and how did
you end up at Microsoft doing the work
you're doing today it's pretty
interesting so when I finished high
school I wasn't really sure what I want
to do yeah I I wasn't sure today I know
what I want really well but back in the
time I didn't know what I want and
computer science in the 90s it was like
pretty new fields like students didn't
major in computer science a lot
it was pretty trendy but nobody figured
out like what should we do with it only
couple of companies that existed back
then out of the Giants were Microsoft
and IBM right there was in Facebook
there wasn't Google so we didn't even
know the size of the job market as a
student in high school so I grew in
Cairo in Egypt and back in the time
there was a Microsoft and there was an
IBM and this is all what I knew about
the world back then right
but when I went in college first I
decided to go to medical school because
my parents wanted to me to go to medical
school but this didn't resonate well
with me
so because I have a lot of passion to
science and physics and math and all
that and my dad is a mathematician so I
had a lot of passion towards math since
I was a kid and problem-solving and all
that but you know at that age I didn't
know what I really love and it's hard to
recognize yourself at the time so I get
in college and then I decided not to do
medicine and then I started exploring I
explored accounting I explored the
economics I explored marketing I
explored a bunch of things and computer
size and from the very first computer
science class it was awesome this is the
thing I want problem-solving right it
resonated a lot with me but I liked the
fact that I did the homework of
exploring other options so when I went
in computer science lots of you said
it's a hard field like you will work day
and night you will only deal with
machines and
that's tough right but I loved it and
when I graduated the last semester it's
interesting because Microsoft back in
the time was sending recruiters to Cairo
to recruit people from my college which
college was that American University in
Cairo okay and it was kind of
interesting because the top people in
class used to go to Microsoft so it was
kind of a good prestige if you get an
offer from Microsoft sure but back in
the time me and another colleague of
mine are the only people in our class
who got an offer from Microsoft here in
Redmond but my parents didn't want me to
come here by myself and leave them I
started my career because I stayed back
in Cairo I started my career in IBM
alternatively and that's where I started
as a full-stack developer and later a
dev manager that's how I started my
journey in computer science but in IBM I
learned lots of rigor loss of discipline
the corporate world and like it was a
good learning that prepared me a lot to
where I am today tell us something we
don't know about you iam okay any
interesting or defining moments in life
an epiphany experience a characteristic
that is defined your direction
personally there are two things I love
to do I love to build dreams and achieve
them so I love to live the dream first
before I achieve it that's me that's why
I'm into that business I think the one
thing that keeps me going is I don't
take no as an answer so I always try to
find another path to my dream and I have
to build the dream embrace it myself so
that I can get my team to execute on it
those are the two key things that I
would say characterize me or define who
I am have you been like that since you
were little yes I would say yes how'd
that go with your mom and dad you know
it's interesting because I was not that
know person to my parents okay yeah not
at all and I'm not a no person in
general but I don't take no as an answer
so if I want something I want it so much
that you might tell me no in
and or but I will go try to open another
door so that I get a yes so I keep
trying and you know I have learned in
life that there isn't anybody who wanted
something very much and didn't get it
you always get what you really want so
much at the end of every podcast I give
my guests the proverbial last word and
our audience is a really eclectic mix of
researchers and devs and other
interested parties so here's your chance
to give some parting advice or thoughts
to anyone across the tech spectrum who
might be interested in joining the
effort to build natural language
capabilities into talking machines
mm-hmm I would say the first thing you
have to have that passion for that
because it's not a straightforward
domain it's not well defined yet so it
will be a journey for you and the other
thing is embrace the science you need to
learn what's going on in that space
learn about the state of the art get to
know what other people did well and
succeeded in and failed ads because
that's very key right and then watch for
real problems to solve don't try to just
go with the crowd after a trend
technology or no you need to do a lot of
thinking around like how can i leverage
whatever I get as input from the science
world into solving a problem I would
encourage everyone to kind of be very
practical
loketh real-world problems and then work
it backwards so instead of starting by
the excitement to the technology start
by the problem and see what technology
would solve that problem all right so
let's just extrapolate there as we
finish up what's next for ahem and
what's next for Louis so the dream is to
have millions of teachers using our AI
programming language to build customary
models and not taking no for an answer
and not taking no for an answer we have
Monsour it's been so great having you in
the booth today thanks for coming on
[Applause]
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Rehan Monsour
and the world of bespoke AI powered by
machine teaching visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]